it's been six months since I bought
Apple's airpods Pro 2 and I wanted to
give you guys an updated long-term
review on both the good and the bad and
if you should buy a discounted brand new
set for as low as 189 dollars right now
on Amazon links down below or if you
should just wait for the airpods Pro 3
and when those will be coming out now I
want to start out with the things that
really surprised me and what I changed
my mind on the first are the updated
controls now the airpods Pro 2 look very
similar to the original models which I
really liked but one new feature is the
ability to swipe on the stem to adjust
your volume when that came out I thought
it was a little bit gimmicky I didn't
think that I would use it but then once
I started to use it I found myself just
using it naturally without even thinking
about it and I'm somebody that has an
Apple watch Ultra so I can just swipe to
adjust the volume but the now playing
app isn't always open or sometimes they
don't have it on my wrist so that has
been amazing not having to even touch my
phone and the next one has been
reliability with the original airpods
Pros I constantly had issues where
sometimes they would auto switch
sometimes they wouldn't sometimes it
would take 10 20 seconds or I would even
have to turn off Bluetooth and then
reconnect it the last six months these
things have been solid now I'm not sure
if that is just the new H2 chip with the
Bluetooth 5.3 that my iPhone 14 pro Max
also has but it has been solid switching
to my Mac has been very quick and it is
so nice to not have bugs that are just
annoying you when you know the way that
they should actually work and the third
thing that really surprised me was the
Apple watch charger compatibility now I
love the Apple added mag and it's into
this so you can charge it with mag safe
and it aligns and then when they added
the Apple watch charger I thought that
was weird I want Apple to go away from
their own standard for the Apple watch
just to go to a standard Qi because I
don't like to have a specific charger
but I have found myself many times where
I needed to charge this and I had an
Apple Watch charger I keep one in my car
or my desk I simply just set it down and
it charges or even in my three in one
just setting it down uh into the wrong
spot at night and then I realize it but
it charges anyway so that is a nice
touch now the next thing I want to talk
about is battery life it has been
incredible now the battery life did get
a little bit better with these new
models but in the real world what I have
noticed is that I have never ran out of
battery using these I think Apple under
quoted them I think there's a little bit
of extra capacity for long term long
longevity because if you didn't know if
your battery dies too fast the maximum
capacity Apple will need to replace
these if you're under warranty and with
that they have the optimized charging
feature which I have kept enabled so
even though I use these all the time I
don't think they've degraded at all
whereas with the previous airpods I
would have them die on me and even after
six months to a year it was noticeable
that the batteries were not lasting that
long now because of that I don't know if
you really need Apple Care Plus I would
always buy them for earpods one of the
only Apple devices that I would buy
AppleCare for because I knew the battery
degraded so quickly that you would need
to replace it but with these updates you
might not need to at least if you're
very careful and you don't lose these
now Apple also added the find me
functionality basically an air tag built
in and that is an amazing feature that
is well worth upgrading in my opinion
yet now I'm not somebody that loses
these very often but that has come in
handy one time for me and the fact that
we have a speaker here for it to make
noises for you to find him is great but
what I like even more is when I do set
them down to charge just to have that
little chime notification for me to know
that yes they are charging that my
charger is plugged in is super nice and
with that I have to talk about noise
cancellation it is phenomenal so much so
that in my last few times flying I have
literally not taken my airpods Max
these things were great before great on
a plane but I think with a lot of
frequencies the airpods Pro 2 are
actually better and they fit in your
pocket they're very comfortable they're
less expensive so when you combine all
the convenience and the fact that the
noise cancellation is so good
um that is just a killer selling point
for these and a killer reason to upgrade
now as far as transparency mode in my
microphone quality Apple's always had
amazing transparency mode but now it is
even better because of the feature
called adaptive transparency where when
you're using them if you have
transparency mode on and there's a loud
sound outside it will actually lower the
volume so now I'm doing yard work it is
amazing and it's a nice little safety
feature to protect your ears and that
way I could be doing things I could
still hear my kids if I turn off the
blower and then when I turn it back on
it lowers the volume I think that it's a
great feature that nobody really
expected that Apple added and it was
awesome now with that when I originally
compared these to the airpods 3 the
airpods 3 actually did a little bit
better in terms of microphone quality
now I don't know if Apple has improved
it with software updates but one thing
that has been great is the voice
isolation feature that they added that
you can use with airpods Pro 2 as well
now that cancels out background sounds
take makes your voice and kind of
isolates it so that's what it's sending
to whoever you're talking to and using
that feature even in loud environments
paired with the microphones that are in
here makes for pretty much the best
um experience using bluetooth earbuds
for making phone calls and now we have
to talk about sound quality Apple made a
really big jump with these they adjusted
the sound profile a lot of audio files
even like snazzy Labs said it was a
really big upgrade the airpods pro
Originals they were really behind
compare the competition even the airpods
3 sounded better in a lot of ways but
these did step it up and I think one
reason they did is because of that H2
chip and uh the fact that the
spatialized audio worked so much better
they added that feature where you can
personalize it and I was really
surprised by how big of a difference
that made I don't know how how that Tech
Works where it looks at your ears and it
Tunes it but it does work and now for
most songs I'm keeping spatialized audio
turned on it makes songs sound like
you're at a live concert you hear the
vocals clearly it expands The Sound
Stage it works really well and that made
me want to have spatialized audio in my
car and then anchor released a speaker
that is Bluetooth and has a spatialized
audio as well and that does a great job
and particularly if you're listening to
lower quality audio when you're
streaming if you're playing through
YouTube it makes low quality audio quite
a bit better so that was impressive now
I also love how loud these get
especially if you're listening to
something quiet like a podcast or
something else having the extra room to
turn it up is really nice and that is
where some other earbuds kind of fall
behind uh and a downside with many of
them so I'm really glad that Apple gives
you that extra room there even though
you can get a warning that says hey
you're listening to stuff too loud I
like that you have that now where do
these kind of fall apart now first off
we have that lightning Port that is
getting more and more annoying as more
devices have USB type c thankfully we
have wireless charging and the fact that
we don't have any better codec for
lossless we've talked about this a lot
in the past
um but Apple did not add it to these and
that was a big disappointment whereas
with different other earbuds and with
Android we now have high-res audio
streaming capabilities same thing with
that anchor speaker that I talked about
and that does improve the quality
especially if you're using Apple music
with their lossless to stream so it is
shocking that apple does not support
their own high quality streaming service
with their own products so I said a lot
of good things about these should you
wait for the airpods pro 3. well we
recently had some leaks and some code
where we have new airpods and a new case
that showed up some people are saying
they are the airpods Pro 3 but I
personally don't think so now I do think
that we might have an update in the fall
but if we have an update the only change
will be USB type c I believe everything
else will stay the same we've also had
rumors about airpods light a cheaper
version that's going to be more
affordable so I think that's a
possibility but that will not come this
year and of course it will not have all
of these features so should you wait for
airpods Pro 3 and when will those come
out well Apple's typically been on about
a two-year cycle sometimes reaching up
to three to update so if we get airpods
Pro 3 it will not be this fall it will
be at least another year after that so
that means you're gonna be waiting a
year and a half and I do not think that
is worth it at all especially when you
can pick these up as low as 100 189
dollars on Amazon I don't think it's
worth the wait pick one up even if has a
lightning Port you have wireless
charging it works great and overall
these are probably the best earbuds that
I've ever bought the sound quality is
amazing
um I rarely use my airpods Max now
because of that and I think you'll be
extremely happy with it so hopefully you
guys enjoyed that update let me know
your thoughts as if you bought them how
are you enjoying them click that Circle
above to subscribe check out one of
those videos right over there there's
been Max and I'll see you in the next
one
[Music]